I'm trying to understand what's going on
with the Washington Redskins here Andrew
what was a better deal what the Redskins
offered or what Kirk Cousins decided to
do we are going to wait till February
March to find out and unfortunately we
don't have an answer right now but the
Redskins continue as I always say to
want to date him and not marry him and I
think their strategy their offer they
publicly put out which you can talk
about to be a mistake shows that that
you know they like him very much they
don't love them and it ultimately gets
back as I always say to the collective
bargaining agreement which allows them
to do this so they can negotiate
aggressively they can negotiate as if
he's not a free agent because he's not
so if he says no ok we'll see you in
February play for us this year what
feels like then both sides got what they
wanted the cousins will play gets paid
and then if he plays well then they can
franchise him if that's the case if not
then he's free to go play for the San
Francisco 49ers and Washington who can't
decide if they want to marry him or just
date him then they can move on to
somebody else it is that how you see it
I think so I also think you know these
people predicting some blockbuster
monster contract from the 49ers or
someone else come March you know it's a
perfect storm they've got to figure out
ok he has a great year
the 49ers don't like what they've had in
quarterback weather the veterans they
signed or the yeah the rookie they
drafted other teams don't have the
priority or they do have the priority
cousins is out there the transition tag
I mean there's a lot of steps to get to
a big free agent contract next year and
ultimately the Redskins know that and if
they put 24 million on them this year
who's to say they won't put 28 million
on them next year which is the
transition tag and let all comers come
and see if they can make an offer that
really floats their boat more than 28
million cap room they've already
allocated so again I continue to wonder
how people see Kirk Cousins
in this extraordinary leverage when he's
just negotiating with one team what did
the derrick karr offer do to Kirk
Cousins or the Redskins I think it made
a deal harder and it's not so much the
25 million average or the 125 or
whatever the number was it's the
starting point so consider this Derek
Carr had a million dollars scheduled for
2017 Kirk Cousins had 24 million
scheduled for 2017 and that's what we'll
make so to be kind of apples to apples
the way you look at these contracts Kirk
Cousins would had to make 23 million
more than Derek Carr and that's a hard
deal to make because when you have these
guys coming off rookie contracts like if
they did Kirk Cousins
after year 3 that would be comparable
but since he's in this advantaged state
with the the number so high this year I
think it made a deal Hart I'm also
looking at this let's say the a
franchise team this year and he has a
good year they franchise him next year
if I'm looking at the money that they
have to pay him that's going to be more
than the guaranteed money they were
going to offer him for this contract in
the first place so if I'm Kirk Cousins
and I really believe in myself
why wouldn't I roll the dice here and
say I can make more money
in two years I don't have to sign this
long-term deal that who knows if I'm
going to make that 72 million dollars
you're going to be offering me I think
it's a good point first of all I don't
think the franchise tag will be in play
next year that number in the mid-30s is
going to be prohibitive but I do think
as I mentioned the transition tag could
be in play and again let all comers come
and see if they can knock Kirk Cousins
socks off to sign an offer sheet here's
the thing Dan it just seems to me that
Kirk Cousins
if the Redskins really wanted to make
this deal happen they could have the the
thing that I think upset the agent was
they wanted to offer basically next
year's karent guaranteed like a
transition tag they offered like twenty
nine additional guarantee and then four
years of unsecured money and I always
talk about NFL contracts a really
illusory and team option
I mean if they made it a shorter deal
where he could have another bite of free
agency maybe in four years or if they
made some kind of additional guarantee
in the third year which again I just
think her cousin's is such a paternal
actually kind guy that he almost wants
to make a deal happen but the Redskins
in my mind didn't try that hard it just
keeps getting back to how they feel
about him loving not loving but liking
you know why would you want to stay with
the team that doesn't view you as a
franchise quarterback again back to the
CBA you have no choice so Kirk Cousins
by the end of this year will have
completed three contracts with his
rookie deal and to franchise tags with
no ability to sniff another team and
that is a restriction that the CBA gives
the Redskins and they've used it and
again people talk about a lot of money
year to year yes but I you know you me
everyone I think they would rather have
security the Redskins just haven't given
her an offer to make that and again to
publicly state an offer where people
like me could pick it apart I don't I
don't get that good to talk to you again
Andrew thank you we appreciate you
crunching numbers for us
always a pleasure Dan that's Andrew
Brandt sports business columnist for the
mmq be calm also Sports Illustrated the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience